what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us are trying to get our lunch
money right do you see how i said that
with great
enunciation because i'm here with plana
and pelina
is basically an english professional she
knows everything of the language i'm an
english professional do not forget that
lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block buy has
three products you can buy and sell
crypt on their crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto take out a us dollar loan
to get your crypto collateral
or you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in that interest paying
account go to block fight.com
pomp blockfy.com i'm an investor i'm a
happy user
you will be too go to blockfy.com what's
up
great so okay cnbc has some like really
weird ads lately i don't know what's
going on
back god bless you god
i felt it coming on that was like a
sneeze that was coming it was coming it
was coming you know what's weird then
weirder than yawning sneezing and
hiccuping hiccupping is actually
you're a master at hiccuping let's go
because we have 10 minutes to finish
this
goldman sachs as close to offering
bitcoin and other digital assets to its
wealth management clients
so it's going to be offering it to the
rich people huh
listen goldman sachs is going to figure
out that bitcoin
doesn't need the suits it doesn't need
the bankers you can literally just go on
the internet and you can buy bitcoin
whenever you want
if you're a rich person you don't need
goldman sachs don't pay goldman sachs
fees
just go on the internet learn how to use
the internet and buy bitcoin yourself
if that's what you want to do the whole
idea that these banks are only offering
it to their rich clients but not to
other clients when it's freely available
on the internet tells you everything you
need to know about the banking business
model
goldman sachs i told you back in 2018
when i met with a bunch of executives
that you guys should go do this now
three years later here's what you're
doing
so the way that i think about this is
that goldman sachs this is net
positive for the bitcoin industry
because they are bringing in more people
more adoption they're bringing awareness
they're talking about it but
oh this is crazy if you're a user don't
wait for goldman to help you get into
bitcoin
do your own research and let's go
european central bank
president christine lagarde said her
institution could launch a digital
currency around the middle of this
decade
if our fellow policymakers give the
project the green light this summer
we need to make sure that we do it right
we owe it to the europeans she said
the whole process let's be realistic
about it will in my view take another
four years maybe a little bit more
so what kind of digital currency that do
they want to launch
government's gonna government what is
gonna take four years to create
what is going on here four or five years
to build something that will be inferior
from a technology standpoint to bitcoin
and the existing stable coins how is it
that a private company can do something
in a matter of weeks but the government
takes five years this is why they are
inefficient this is why it's a bad use
of resources
and it is also why they are going to do
it it will take them five years
but they will be drastically drastically
behind and what we are watching is we
are watching the disruption
of the legacy banking system including
central banks and their
fiat dirty dirty fiat currency
simply because better superior
technology
is being created by technologists
literally on my forehead you can see
where
both lights are like it is a mirror
it looks like you have horns you look
like the devil
dapper you're not like the devil you're
an angel but i just wanted you to know
that you
have horns like in why am i not a
unicorn then
because they only have uni corn what
which is one horn
anthony nobody wants rational thought
around here but i'ma keep y'all
paying attention you're in trouble
okay i know decacorn is 10.
what would two be you better stop before
you you're a unit corpse
somebody's calling me see all right um
ready hello
hey i'm recording lunch money right now
i have to call you back this is what
happens
say hi to everyone what's up everyone
that's my brother joe
he called me so i had to answer bye all
right let's keep going
he called i had to answer you didn't you
didn't say anything about my joke about
unicorps
yeah because it was zappos
we need a live studio audience dapper
labs announced a 305 million dollar
funding round tuesday from another batch
of
nba stars and a venture capital firm
backing its runaway hit
nba top shot kevin durant michael jordan
the investment firm co2
and a deep bench of 30 athletes plus the
rapper 2 chainz i was just thinking
about him the other day
how many chains he got two have filed
into the non-fungible token firm
wow it's very valuable it's 2.6 billion
that's why we're a good team because you
were going to really struggle with co2
until i helped you i knew how to say
code did you i knew how to spell it
i don't pronounce things i just read
okay
nerd uh dapper labs continues to
absolutely print money literally they
are printing money they simply take
nba highlights and they create nfts
they're called nba top shots
and they sell them for lots and lots of
money the big question is when all of a
sudden you can get your money out of the
system right now it's very hard to get
your money out of the system
if you can get your money out of the
system how many people are selling
rather than buying
when you have closed systems prices go
up because demand
can't have a release valve now if they
create the release valve we're gonna see
what happens but
congrats to all the folks at dapper labs
they're working hard they're pushing
the pace of innovation and this is
pretty cool to see i'm getting hot
okay the at-home fitness startup tonal
said it has raised an additional 250
million dollars in funding
valuing the business at 1.6 billion
wow dragoneer led the round along with
cobalt
capital el catterton and sapphire
ventures
the company says it plans to use the
fresh capital to accelerate its
marketing efforts to open more
brick-and-mortar stores and to invest in
logistics and manufacturing
people working out during the pandemic
yes but do you think that they should be
opening
brick and mortar stores no why
hot take it's actually the best time to
probably do it you get really really
cheap real estate you can swing the unit
economics in your favor
you probably can get great locations in
major cities and
something like this is probably uh got a
much higher conversion if people see it
they touch it they feel it they watch it
in action maybe they go into a little
workout
then they want to buy it okay ready
yes dating.com reveals
dad bonds are the majority of singles
body type
preference yep that's right ladies and
gentlemen
they all those extra hours of the gym
are really not worth it
dating.com is saying that the results of
its latest member survey reveal
the most desirable body type among
singles is the dad bod
the online dating giant also shares tips
for feeling confident in your own skin
while online dating we live in a soft
society
um it's ask lunch money time hashtag ask
ellen in the comments below
i'm laughing because i just said stuff
that she made us cut out
rahul das can you explain what dapper
labs
nba top shot is i read that it is a
blockchain company but want to know more
a lot of big nba players like kevin
durant and klay thompson
are invested in it as well thank you
well i'm glad that we just talked about
it so
the whole key to nba top shot is that
uh they basically take highlights they
tokenize them or create nfts and then
they auction them off and anyone can go
in and they can buy it
and so one of the great ideas is that
you basically are taking highlights and
you're exposing it to free market
competition
and it's getting repriced by the public
and so some of these are selling for
five dollars some of them are selling
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
but it's essentially just a highlight
packaged up almost think of it as like a
virtual
or a multimedia version of a sports card
it's not about one player it's about the
actual event itself
awesome moist time it is day i think uh
oh
he didn't say 31 something moisture
safe he said please don't end me because
of this 33
um youtube keeps deleting my comments
including this one my one from yesterday
got deleted where i
recommended an afternoon kayaking and
bill at bill
bags state park and in a sunset dinner
at whiskey joe's
every time i comment it gets deleted and
after we add it i was really busy this
past day and i didn't check to see if it
had been deleted i swear i commented
yesterday i must be shadow banned
please give me another chance i have big
tech fighting against me
he even went the length to prove to me
he was moist
through instagram showed me all these
things moist don't worry about
it we understand i don't know why
youtube keeps
devoting you you're safe until i find
out you're dm and my wife
we're gonna have problems i'll be dm in
my life he was very appropriate
but you're safe i said it yesterday on
the episode i figured that you had
commented i have faith do you want to
tell moist what we talked about
what did we talk about uh oh
what are you talking about no just say
it whatever if i if i talked about it
oh moist okay we're done we're done with
moist pelina doesn't want to do moist
anything no i do
she doesn't want to do soggy she doesn't
want to do wet she doesn't want to do
any of that stuff i just think he's been
through
enough it's 90 days is too long of a
time all right
moist what i need you to do is dm my
wife don't dm my wife but dm my wife
your number no actually not your number
your email address we don't need your
number
send us your email address and i'll send
you an email
and we'll get on the phone maybe we'll
record it maybe we want to have it
decided yet but i'm tired of
listening to all this nonsense and uh i
need other things to do so just send
your email
so what are we gonna do are we gonna
bring moist on maybe i haven't decided
yet maybe i need to do a private call to
check him out
see if he's legitimate no i think the
first call has to be on lunch money
okay my brother just called me so maybe
i'll just call
moist on my cell phone all right but
then moist will have my cell phone
number
that's it for today bye
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 percent interest on a deposit
in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends